Claire Danes is the most fantastic young
actress I've ever come across
she she's up ball of emotion a
powerhouse as I like but I'm proud you
have but thankful that you have proud
can I never be of what I a it's great to
work with her I mean she's she's able to
get into the stuff like that and really
feed you what you need you know what I
mean he's brilliant and he's actually
amazing at what he does and he's one of
the most interesting and smart people I
think I've ever met and I've had a
really good time working with him and
learning about him as a person I have a
lot of respect for him he's a good guy
thousand times the worse to want thy
light when we when I first did the
audition she was the only girl that like
came up right to my face
I was like doing the lines and wasn't a
face but wasn't afraid to like grab my
back of my neck and like kiss me and
like hold my hand and all the other
girls were so staring off under the
stars like trying to be flowery and
beautiful and she was just like hardcore
about those so it was cool the dude is
the genius he's been a genius for
decades now and he's not very old so
he's such such an exquisite actor and
we've all adored him and yeah he's been
under appreciated in that kind of formal
you know blingy sense